une belle photo de famille dans la salle
du conseil municipal de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux réunit autour
d'une même table des spationautes ou
encore Julie Robinson responsable à la
NASA en tout cette agence spatiale
internationale conviée par le CNES pour
réfléchir à l'interaction entre travaux
dans l'espace et recherche médicale une
rencontre au sommet qui n'est pas dû au
hasard il y a quelques mois le radioclub
de Montigny avait organisé une liaison
entre le lycée Descartes et la Station
spatiale internationale depuis cela a
donné des idées à l'agence spatiale
française on est très favorable au
développement de d'activités spatiales
dans de nombreuses communes en France et
Montigny-le-Bretonneux semblent
dimensionner pour accroître ses
activités dans le domaine spatial il y a
un très bon lycée il y a un radioclub
amateur qui est qui a qui est très
motivé et puis comme on l'a dit une
école d'ingénieur dans le domaine
aérospatial une fac de médecine qui veut
également se développer dans direction
bref le terrain est extrêmement
favorable pour que le CNES et
Montigny-le-Bretonneux développent ces
activités spatiales ici l'école
d'ingénieur dont parle François Spiro
c'est l'ESTACA l'école forme de futurs
ingénieurs chargés d'inventer les
transports de demain transporterest
comme spatiaux l'école vient de signer
un accord de partenariat avec
l'entreprise safran à Élancourt elle
forme 1500 étudiants par an et va
s'implanter en 2015 à Montigny tout
logiquement ce qui nous a intéressé à
ces à la fois tout le tissu industriel
dans le domaine des transports il y a
beaucoup de nos partenaires habituels
que soit dans le domaine automobile ou
dans le domaine aéronautique ils sont
aux alentours Montigny de 51 en Yvelines
et plus largement les Yvelines des
partenaires académiques aussi ça fait
longtemps qu'on travaille avec
l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Montigny-le-Bretonneux Cité de l'espace
mais oui pourquoi pas en tout cas le
SNES ne compte pas s'arrêter en si bonne
voie